good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy when's Tuesday
oh my god what a slow ahead of yourself
because if it were Wednesday it would be
my birthday
and if we're Wednesday I would be
humping everyone cuz it's hump day but
it's only Tuesday and you know what this
is gonna be a great week obviously
because it's my birthday it's a short
week for you which means we're changing
things up for the toast so it's a it's a
fun and diverse week and I think it's
gonna be great we have Jack the neck or
Jack Vanek I like the neck I fit the
neck I said right I think for me just
rolls off the tongue easier but she's
coming on the show later today and I am
so excited we're gonna complete the lady
game trifecta and also when we went on
lady gang I realized that I am a jack
really yeah just like her energy
i I think I relate most to Jack well no
jack with like a sprinkle of a Becca and
a sprinkle of the Kelty but I think I'm
predominantly Jack well Becca wasn't
there so I didn't really get to like
experience their whole vibe in person so
I don't know who I am I'm very healthy
Am I yeah yeah yeah she talks the most
I'm just like the most energy energetic
like fun spunky yeah but we didn't get
to see Becca in actually and so like
where does Becca fall in when it's the
three of them and I'm maybe I'm ugly and
I'm just getting to the episodes
Rebecca's and it's just so crazy I'm
like I know her you know and she like
she didn't get enough lines should be
enough time agree never delved into
Katie storyline like what made her want
to make Marnie think she was fat that
was so evil who hurt her no totally I
know the way she's talked about Marnie's
mom who was like the lady like it was so
me and like watching back these episodes
it's like it's so painful to watch like
them be so mean to her that was really
really terrible yeah but who hurt you
kitty no literally like that evil just
doesn't come from anywhere like it's
learned right so we could have explored
that maybe on the Glee reboot which will
inevitably come soon because all we do
is reboot you mean the Glee boot the
Glee do this snitch is here on the
snitch Kenzo is the snatch and so is the
snatch she dropped her new episode of
the snatch allure today it's been a
while you took maybe like a month hiatus
ever since The Bachelor she eventually
ended yeah because I just like didn't
really know what to do with it after but
then I saw the demand was high and you
know I just have to answer I just do
answer the call I do what the people
tell me and now I know it's just a basic
this is why we got the boo from this
yeah Oh totally and now it's just
basically a podcast like about my life
and and also the bachelor
but yeah so I recorded it yesterday and
you have a big update on your status of
my life of my job here at the toast and
I'm not gonna tell you here because I
want to go yes click Dutch it Margot yes
snatcher making moves and now it's a
personal podcast that like if you ever
want to know what the snitch does after
the show which we all want to know um
and there were so many really cute
moments with her and her roommate where
they talk about how they're just like
living life and they come home to their
apartment and they're just like so happy
because they love their apartment and
they they put on this they were like
some people come to their apartment they
like have a glass of wine and they text
their ex she was like we come home we
put on a song that we love and we dance
around the living room and we're just
like we love it here like after night
out we were so drunk and we got home we
played homecoming queen six times on
repeat and just like enjoyed it that's
so nice in like that's the stuff we want
to hear from you just like young in the
city this podcast isn't gonna be for all
the people who listen to this podcast
because you are like younger living a
younger life your gen Z correspondent
your Arctic talk correspondent yeah I'm
trying to like build a new audience now
oh I do listen you should be so honored
to have our audience the trusters are
everything course I hear you because
doing what she's talking about like
college and things that like no college
and you know what cloud like we could
stand have a younger audience here
saying we're too old no I'm saying we
want to get everyone we need to cast a
wide net and that's what we're doing at
tienen that is what we believe in young
brilliant talent we do we also believe
in southern talent raven and adams new
show tonight with ribbon and adam we
visited southern town I'm defying iTunes
check it out the reviews are in there
rave Raven has the most the reviews are
in and their Raven she's the most
wonderful voice for podcasting its
southern and smooth and she's so funny
and it's a really great show they have a
great dynamic so if you're a single
toaster snookin for love in all the
wrong places check it out speaking of
snookin for love
I watched Mike Sorrentino and Lauren
sorrentinos Lauren T know their 20
minute wedding video last night they got
married at like a beautiful castle in
New Jersey I never heard of it it was
actually like I'm emotional
really beautiful cuz you were I remember
like he's going to prison right and he
was just like it was almost like
bittersweet like he looked kind of sad
the whole time but like in a happy way
come on say it was really nice and it
was cool they put in a lot of snippets
of Vinny and Pauly 's speeches
oh that's cool Vinny Pauly and Ronnie
were groomsmen oh they only had four
groomsmen and they were three out of
four like it's crazy how these kids have
really been friends for so long yeah and
that like this show gave them a family
yeah you know like they're not just
ghosts coworkers yeah their family yeah
it's really sweet it was a good video
glad to hear it we're gonna reek up
tents with the Stars at the end of this
episode along with anything else we need
to recap
I watched a new Netflix movie last night
I think it's gonna be all the rave it's
called holiday in the wild with Kristin
Davis from Sex in the City and oh my god
okay I watched a press junket that they
did they have literally no chemistry
like it was so awkward like the person
and I'm like what are your plans for the
holidays like in your real home and Rob
Lowe was like you know it's all about
the tree and the singing and Kristin
Davis is like well I'm southern and we
love to bake it was just like the two
could not have less in common less
chemistry it was just like you would
never know they spent the last three
months together filming everybody well
they're great actors because I would
never know and it's a really great movie
just so many different elements to it
and just like I think you'll really like
it because um there's a lot of elephants
justice for Elephants a documentary
about an apology elephants you should go
watch the documentary and just we need
to be doing more to conserve the
elephant population I don't know at the
end of the movie they say that oh wait
that actually you know that makes a lot
of sense when I used to be an intern
Kristin Davis came in for an interview
and her whole platform like after Sex in
the City
it's all about saving elephants she does
these like trips to Africa she literally
did a movie to save Allen that's
presumably she doesn't really need to
work I guess that's why she did that
said enough let's movie because they
agreed to help or charity it wasn't sad
it was really beautiful
I'm pretty sure they filmed on-location
in Africa because I don't think those
were always in Africa and it was
beautiful like just masterful scenery
okay
loved it and he's really cute Rob Lowe
he is I don't know if I mentioned this a
time or twenty but I did go to the roast
of Rob Lowe Comedy Central a couple
years ago it's where I met Pete Davidson
um such a good note I'm you know I need
was sitting all the way in the back but
I really got the sense that Rob Lowe was
like this mature handsome man you know
except TV have sex with like a six year
old are coming I've never heard that but
that's well the jokes were he is
that like have sex with the teenager and
never just like dates younger women no
no it was like a whole scandal mark can
you google it like I think there was a
sex tape no please don't because like we
need more context um that's what we need
the contacts for okay there everyone's
making jokes about it at the roast okay
cuz I don't know if I showed you I am
yeah we you we're at that rose I mean
like in the audience and I was on the
red carpet co-hosting correspond a very
very close did you get my picture taken
if you google it was one of the first
pictures that come up I look like a
baked potato because I'm wrapped in tin
foil wearing like the silver metallic
jackets such terrible call baked
potatoes are so good
in 1988 rob lowes involved in a scandal
over videotape of him having sex with
two females one of whom was 16 thank you
well you just ruin the movie for me
thank you
but you already watch it so it's gonna
be around um and it was good and I would
recommend it and it's the perfect sort
of like Netflix movie it's just like
falling in love you know if it got me
through three hours of my life yeah and
where I was intermittent fasting and I
couldn't eat and it distracted me
falling in love was honestly like one of
the worst movies of this year like so
terrible not terrible no no it was it
wasn't great but it wasn't terrible it
was terrible it was like it was terrible
he was great um we have Jackman XO we
gotta go through we gotta get through so
usually this lets us know when it's time
but I guess she's like she's been that
snatchler high usually you ask me if
it's time okay it's at a time it's time
well it's time for the past five stories
that you need to know before you wake up
and take a bite out of your morning
toast and it is but I have to share a
personal anecdote about one of our
sponsors
because as you know well actually might
not know today's episode is brought to
you by noon they have a changing
solution that helps users learn to
develop a new relationship with food
through personalized courses it's based
on psychology they'll teach you why you
do the things you do and arms you with
the tools to break the bad habits and
replace them with better ones so
yesterday I went to the doctor just for
like a checkup
you know it's getting my blood pressure
and I was telling her and actually she
told me I was just like a little
overweight and I was like thanks doc oh
thanks ah I was just telling her how
like I like I will never lose weight
like that's like my thing like I just
can't like she's like I could put
together like a and I'm like honestly
like I can't like you I could waste your
time and have you put together a plan
for me but like we both know I'm not
gonna do it and then she was like you
use any apps I'm like no she's like
honestly I don't recommend many
um because like I think a lot of them
like you won't actually use but I
recommend new and I was like did you
just say new comm flash shows do you
recommend new show do it new and I would
start telling patients new me cuz I
should shows like are you getting me
like they sounded so obnoxious I'm like
this was a rebroadcast but like it was
so crazy and I really like cemented for
me that new mork's new really works I
love Noom I've had I'm a goal setter and
you know I'm a goal not really but I'm
goal-oriented I like to like see my
progress I like to see where where I am
and where I'm going and new makes that
so easy I've been using neumes in
started working with us on the toast and
like it really makes a huge difference
so it's not a diet it's a healthy and
easy to stick to way of life no food is
considered good better off limits they
just teach you moderation and can be
used in conjunction with many
preexisting popular diets if you want
one of the biggest and most accurate
food databases available a zoom and they
let you track your meal habits visualize
portion sizes and calorie density at a
glance we are all strapped for time new
masks you to commit 10 minutes a day
just for yourself your human if you go
off track there's no shame just tips to
help you get back on track tomorrow chat
with your goal specialist and Noom
community to get and give help to people
going through the same things that's the
best part of name it's similar to the
toast it's community based yes we love a
community base time you don't have to
change it all in one day
small steps to make big progress sign up
for your trial at Noom comm slash toasts
n-o-o-o m.com slash toast what do you
have to lose visit new mom slash toast
to start your trial today that's Noom
comm slash toast the last weight loss
program you'll ever need sign-on feel
amazing okay who's ready for our first
story big big news I'm so excited about
it making travel arrangements now Kelly
Clarkson announces 2020 Vika Stratus
residency with epic medley of her famous
songs Kelly Clarkson is about to add
another job to her very busy schedule
Las Vegas headliner the singer announced
the news on her talk showed the Kelly
Clarkson show on Friday surrounded by a
group of showgirls it's not an April
Fool's joke but it does save her you
April 1st at the Zappos Theatre at
Planet Hollywood Resort that would seem
like an April Fool's joke directed and
targeted at me like to go all the way to
Vegas and I could see that happening to
me couldn't you see that happening yeah
no but this this can't be a joke because
it makes so much sense I think like the
success of Kelly's show really shows how
she's really like she's a mix of like
middle America gay icon
and just like all around popstar and I
think like the success of our show it
really indicates like how much of a
household name she really isn't like we
thought she was before but like now we
know she is like the proof is in the
pudding and anyone deserves a residency
it's her
agree and if anyone is going to anyone's
residency it's me and like one of my
friends is having a bachelor party in
Vegas fun in 2020 Sam so like oh yeah
come I mean it's not my party to it my
people are like we're like in Vegas at
the same meal I could use that strategy
so yeah yeah and I just want to make
sure like she schedules in if it's nap
time like I'm going to Kelly Clarkson
that isn't that is a must-see for me so
that's really exciting and I just want
to say like all you [ __ ] have been
sleeping on Kelly Clarkson for years all
this [ __ ] has not been and everything
that I love usually that gets cancelled
true just or something at words the band
breaks up and like so for me to see like
my girl soaring right now yeah it's a
good time to be a Kelly Clarkson's dad
okay great time to be a Kelly Clarkson
fan and like I just couldn't be happier
I'm happy for you for being happy for
her also I just like would be absolutely
remiss if she didn't sing piece by piece
and cry like she did on American Idol
and make Keith Urban cry like I need a
holograph hologram of Keith Urban
standing there crying while she's
singing a piece by piece like crying
over like her absentee father you know
right yeah or like she needs like
prosthetic tears for every show like I
don't expect her to emot-- at every show
yeah but um piece by piece
isn't the same without the teacher by
the way at our show when we went to her
concert did she do piece by piece
she did it was a piece by piece was
before it was before that performance I
think you know that performs was really
I mean she was like seven months
pregnant yeah and like really so did I
she was crying because she was like
pregnant it was just all coming full
circle and she was like literally
minutes away from delivering a baby
literally like if she squatted the baby
what they think when she's just singing
and I was like a pop anthem on a tour
she like broke it down here there's no
success so it wasn't as emotional I know
like we say this all the time but I do
think we should plan a trip around this
and go to opening night I'm we gonna
with me and we're going to opening night
Lady Gaga and like I'm not gonna lie
like not to make you feel bad but it was
[ __ ] incredible look into Vegas
weekend and it's surrounded on Kelly
Clarkson I would love to and I think
Hicks out of a club again yeah Margit
was like a liability in Vegas honestly
she knows how to ruin your good time cuz
you get to kicked out of the club it was
one time Margo literally walked just
Princeton to the DJ booth started push
some buttons and got us thrown out okay
it was one time and every other time
we've been to Vegas I've been a champ
and honestly it should work out for the
best because we got so we had to go home
super early because everyone was still
in the club and me and my girl got
kicked out we tried to get my shirt was
getting married the next day so it's
time to go so our flight was at noon but
because we got in bed by like 1:30 we
actually switched to the 9 a.m. and we
got home sooner you're welcome us
leaving for Vegas
two days before Olivia's wedding to
spend the weekend with TPG because he
got us tickets to Lady Gaga's opening
night it might have been one of the
craziest most selfish things we've ever
done but I'd do it again most selfish
things you've ever done oh my god but
honestly like first well we got such
good pictures from that weekend I feel
like our friendship with tbg like took a
step to the next level where like it was
family at that point yeah I mean so many
memories you falling face person could
care less she was so happy for you
actually didn't care like it was me I go
I get like I was gonna meet you guys
done more that night like you were
texting me at like literally having a
clock and you're like get on a 9:00 a.m.
flight and come to Vegas because TBG
ends up having one more ticket yeah but
I wound I'm not doing it mostly because
I didn't have a dress for Olivia's
wedding yet they needed to get them
tailored and also like there needs to be
a sister and I was happy to let like you
guys like you guys were selfish and I
was selfless and letting you do my thing
we really appreciate your selflessness
because it was rocking time ya know and
that's how it should be you only live
once and you also will only get
opportunities like that never you get
those opportunities never and if you
ever getting like a cool opportunity you
take it but I'm gonna ask to be G what
kind of credit card we need to be
eligible for Kelly Clarkson presale oh
you know I've been getting all the
emails because I'm her number one fan
and I am eligible I've been getting
presale close okay because like we got a
yes but I also need like front-row
Center
yeah granny Gaga had the front like five
rows be a pit which like we had pit
seats which was cool because it was
close but I [ __ ] hate standing at a
concert I like the option to sit I know
I agree but TPG loves to stand because
he's so much taller than everyone that
he literally is a perfect view so
whenever we go to concerts I went to
Eurovision together we stood he loves
his hand and also he's a man and like it
has more stamina than me a hundred
percent yeah no okay next story is
really crazy I saw it on your Instagram
last night and then I saw this in the
paper I've been following it and I'm
very upset by it and I'm really feeling
couldn´t stop talking about it with Ben
last night well Kim Kardashian wants to
get Rodney Reed off death row like like
she needs a seven she has stepped in she
is tweeting at Governor Abbott so Rodney
Reed is a man who is accused of murder
he is set to be executed on November
20th he's been in prison for like
evarin like everyone apparently just
like knows that he's innocent and like
nobody cares yeah and all this evidence
has come out to substantiate his
innocence and to also we like there is a
real what's the word suspect but he's
dead right
no he's in jail oh yes you're right like
the real suspect is in jail for like
some similar atrocities
whereas Rodney Reed like had never done
anything like this ever and now it's
time to take it to Kim Kardashian so
November 20th that's like so soon that
tells you I think over a million people
have signed a petition but like I don't
know petitions do anything I'm not gonna
lie yeah the only thing that does
anything is Kim Kardashian so first she
started tweeting at the governor she
said please Governor Abbott how can you
execute a man when since his trial
substantial evidence that would
exonerate Rodney Reed has come forward
and even implicates the other person of
interest I urge you to do the right
thing so I the governor can attend
someone's hands yes and the governor can
stop this but I think the president can
too so maybe like Kim is just going to
the governor first and then I respect
but maybe she'll call him the big guns
no but this is no time for respect like
just who can get it done yeah it's like
I'm about to just [ __ ] fly down to
Texas and go to governor's house and
knock on his [ __ ] door he's not
answering anyone everyone's tweeting at
him he's acting like he doesn't know his
Twitter password like please we know you
know your password
yeah no I'm like but we have to be able
to find Governor Abbott his daughter is
definitely a toaster where in the world
is mr. governor Abbott when the [ __ ] are
you bro check your [ __ ] Twitter a
checker GM's if Governor Abbott is your
dad or your uncle where your cousin or
your second cousin and watch the toast
and you watch the toast like please just
Tom to check his Twitter came and
tweeted that him yeah also um I don't
want to speak in like you know doomsday
kinds of terms but if this does end up
happening like I will be so upset like
if there's a protest I'm going like I'm
will be really protests right now um
like to stop it from happening what's
today's date November 5th day before my
birthday okay beanies
it's nuts two weeks I'm not that's like
eight business days but now that Kim
knows about it like I think it's gonna
get done no I was worried she didn't
know and I don't think my DMS are open
like should I send this to her oh my god
anyways am i insulting her by thinking
she might not definitely know I know but
and I think she tweeted about it like a
while ago yeah so she knows once Kim
knows like where we're chilling that's a
crazy that's a crazy concert I know
you know like the criminal justice
system hangs in the hands of Kim
Kardashian
and we're in great hands and you know
what I'm okay with that right
interesante and hopefully you know it
I'm very much looking forward to justice
being served like we will keep you
updated on this story I really hope that
there's a positive update because this
is just so abhorrent
agreed next story and we're moving a
little quickly today because we have gas
yeah news that I did not see coming
after like all of Teddy Mellencamp's
talks on watcher happens I'm about how
John and Meg love housewives meg Ryan
and John Mellencamp split after
engagement I can't believe this he
didn't want to get married again
Mikko Ryan and John Mellencamp have
called it quits one year after
announcing their plans to Wed rumors
swirled about the pair when the actress
was seen without her engagement ring
while recently attending the Governor's
Award this one is all about the
governors yeah she was spotted the next
morning without the ring while running
errands in Los Angeles I wonder if she
saw Governor Abbott at the governor's
Awards right and maybe she's whispered
something to him and maybe things are
happening maybe I guess he didn't want
to get married again the source tells
people he's been married three times
before this is like when we were saying
with Cynthia Bailey yesterday it's like
okay if you're 25 and the guy you're
dating like won't commit and doesn't
want to get married like okay I
understand you leaving like you need to
be fulfilled like you need to have kids
you want to get married you want to have
that type of life that traditional life
okay but it's like when you're older and
you're you've been married and your kids
are grown like when you're gonna go
fixated on getting married and like
maybe ruining potentially good
situations just because you're so
focused on getting married like what's
the point yeah like I feel like if I
ever camp that really can't be it you
know just married like God forbid a
million times like I'm never never gonna
get divorce ever but like let's say I'm
50 I find myself single Ben dies or
something okay it's the only way I'd be
single and Ben dies government not gonna
win a million times cause she'll um and
you know I fall in love again
I don't not gonna care about getting
married like I'm just gonna be happy
like to be happy yeah you know yeah I
who was saying that Dorinda - Rinna made
an excellent point she said marriage is
for the young and with John like it's
just there was really no point in
getting married I really understood that
me too I don't know and now in holiday
in the wild I don't want to spoil it for
everyone but she finds herself in a very
similar situation mm-hmm actually that
happens in the first minute of the movie
I saw it in the trailer like her husband
like leaves her
the day the kid goes to college like
such a cliche he walks out the door and
so does the bags already passed oh my
god oh my bags packed like is that such
is that really such a thing where it's
like the minute the kids go to college
we were just saying how we're hearing a
lot of stories about like people whose
parents are getting divorced likely
later in life so I guess maybe it is
it's like the kids are grown you don't
have to do it for the kids anymore and
like you just want to now you want to
start the toast totally totally well
this is actually really sad because I
feel like John Mellencamp and meg Ryan
like they are [ __ ] endgame for like a
lot of people not for me I don't know
these people but Ryan it's not Teddy's
mom right no who is Teddy's mom mrs.
Mellencamp got it one of the first three
lives Yeah right but like it would be
like if in 20 years John Mayer and
Cameron Diaz got together like that
would be so exciting for us right you
know new big stars on their own later in
life it's like finding love that's
actually a great comparison you know so
I really was here for this but it didn't
work out I hope Teddy's okay me too
I know she really liked me I didn't she
was close to Meg I also think she likes
to the clout Meg brought to her like she
could go on my trap inside and say you
know I was talking to Meg and she said
she loves Erika you know yeah people
like like the cloud also I want to talk
about um what's up inside because I
watched last night the episode with
Ashton from below deck and Christine ray
and Hilda oh my god so first saw
Christine Ray she was also at the roast
of Alec Baldwin she's very funny she and
she is that kind of irrelevant which
makes me sad because she played such an
iconic role and and the ass if she got
royalty checks from Sabrina and she said
yeah of course I give them to my
daughter it was 11 cents last month okay
and then she said someone called him was
like what do you think about the new
Sabrina reboot and she was like I know
anything about anyway and Hilda she's
like I love her I love this show I just
like need her to stop hash tagging and
Hilter like she's in Hilda 2.0 and I'm
an Hilda it was very funny she's super
she's a comedian so she's very funny it
was a very odd episode now like they
were really objectify and I don't really
believe in like male objectification
like men can be objectified like it's
not a thing like it's just it's just not
and they do it all the time on watch
shop and side but ash Jen I guess in
this week's episode of below deck like
did a little striptease for the gas
because I think use to be a stripper
and they were just like sexualizing him
so much and he was so visibly
uncomfortable it was like such an
awkward episode that's really really
awkward yeah still not over 11 months
because when you think like when
someone's iconic show you're just like
Oh their royalties they're set for life
but I actually didn't think that about
Sabrina because I've never seen it aired
you only get those royalty checks when
you get Cindy handed and you're playing
right now it doesn't have a time stop it
like there was a time when it was always
on like replay is it on like Netflix is
it on any treatment services I think not
no but we should bring it back oh and
then they were joking that's why Melissa
Joan Hart sin all these hallmark movies
right at home girl's gotta eat did you
see I'm last night at the Giants game a
black cat made its way onto the field
yes oh my god I was laughing so hard for
those who don't watch sports or give a
[ __ ] like myself Ben told me that in the
middle of the game it's black hat like
came out of nowhere nowhere I was
obviously so scared it was actually
really sad who's running around the
field and delayed the game because they
were trying to get him off the field and
so Andy did it as a Mazel the day and
Christine was like it's a love that is
so Salem it was such a Salem thing I'd
hold a thing to say
it's crazy that like I know so much
about like we used to watch it all the
time but I would never say like I'm a
Sabrina the Teenage Witch Stan no but
like I've seen every episode that I am
yeah crazy time I am what I am I am what
I am Stan okay next story um I just love
talking about these people and now
Caitlyn Carter is talking about herself
she wrote an essay about falling in love
with Miley Cyrus she's oh they're chic a
very good writer I've read the first
half and then you know when you open up
a tab on like Facebook or something when
you open up a story on Facebook and in
your phone yeah and I just assumed it
was on Safari so I went back to it but
then it was gone yeah by the way they
need you'd liked it I would appreciate
if they took me out of Facebook yeah
or Twitter that happens they'll never
take you out of Facebook they will keep
you invited until you are dead it will
keep you here until 4:00 right but um so
I started reading it enough to know
she's a great writer and this was a
really interesting article Caitlyn
Carter fell in love with Miley Cyrus in
the short time they were a couple she
penned in sa Pharrell in which she
opened about up and opened up about her
ongoing journey to discover her
sexuality and said their relationship
was the real deal quote this past July I
went on vacation with a female friend
the next thing I knew I was in love with
her it wasn't quite that simple of
course but it also wasn't very
complicated either until that trip it
had never crossed my mind that I was
even capable of loving a woman the way I
loved her but after reflecting on my
romantic history I realized
never had a type so she talks a lot
about their romance and just like labels
in general and I still ship I don't know
yeah I me then Miley unfollowed her I
know and she unfollowed Liam and they
also put up like another we have video
of them making out yesterday I feel like
Cody stole her phone and unfollowed
these people because definitely seems
like Miley and Caitlyn have bad but I
want to tell you something I want to get
your opinion on something speaking of
Cody you know he won the Australian mass
singer like I said if it spending so
much time on my youtube channel and I
watch this video and it was the title
was the Australian masked singer stole
our song and basically there are these
youtubers that I've dug 200,000
subscribers or names like college and
it's a boy and a girl in there like a
music do they create covers and there
are music and they did like a whole
rendition of bad guy by Billy Eilish
where like they changed the chord
progression it was much more it was like
a rock vibe and apparently someone on
that are showing my singer like did bad
guy in the exact same cover that they
did which like they basically made
themselves like changing all the chords
and the octaves I mean they were like on
here talking about they're gonna see the
masked singer but like is that stealing
like a cover you know I mean it's like
stealing someone's harmony oh I don't
know yeah we're good because it's
already a cover so you're covering the
cover yeah and but you're just like
copying the way someone covered an
original song you know I don't think
that's stealing but I just think when
ass like you should give credit but you
don't get asked those things well then
she did get asked on a morning show that
they clipped and she was just like you
know I'd listen to my daughter's
playlist because it was an older woman
who did it and I just you know I sang
which he likes mmm yeah interesante
interest on but like they didn't write
the song right I don't know that's a
little too had my paygrade
yeah anyway he's Miley and Caitlin just
I just came so came in when it came in
when it was like so lovely while it
lasted you look like Caitlin today I
look like Halen today okay bring a bun
yeah a low bun inside part oh my god
things how does everyone feel about my
grandma guides today I'm into it it's
not grandma she's like toddy grandma
yeah you're Betty Winkle right now Oh
totally except she doesn't dress like a
grandmother that's why she's so right
I'm like the opposite of batty wait
my own person we dress like a grandma
yeah hilarious anyways I just thought it
would be fun for my birthday energy week
I'm kind of over reporting on like the
endless like the cycle of Miley Cyrus's
like romance well same I don't report on
the stories that like hurt and Kody like
being another Instagram but when we can
get some clarity I'll make the situation
that happened this summer via Caitlin's
essay I think you find it interesting
and I'm still holding out hope for like
Miley I'm sorry Caitlin and Brody and
yeah me too we do it all Sam I think
when you're so invested in pop culture
I'm like you talk about it so much story
is that once we're like fiery like you
start to resent the people like even
Chloe interested like we talk about that
for so long and I was like obsessed with
it and then I started to hate them blac
Chyna and Rob and now it's like Miley
and her love affairs like I'm starting
to hate her yeah that I think a lot of
people not even this is love affairs but
just like the way that she's going about
things with Cody right now well it's
just odd but it's not like it's not my
decision to say what she should do or
shouldn't do I'm just like I'm an I've
had enough yep like a wellness check
though I'm Addison Brown and Liam
Hemsworth I won't know if they're going
strong did you see her Halloween costume
yes rise and shine she did like so many
videos she's so funny so funny I just
really like it so sad cuz we saw them at
a first date so like it very well could
have went nowhere and we never would
have known about it but now that we know
about it more like so impassioned about
it like we need it to like sustain yeah
yeah but I think she's also in Atlanta
working I'm sure he's working so maybe
they're good yeah like but we have to
wait till they both get to New York
again
yeah sustenance you know what they say
it's Kay Kay okay our fifth and final
story is some really exciting
interesting pertinent business and our
business is brought to you by article
article is easiest way to make your
space look beautiful right now they're
all about no fuss entertaining from
lounge abou poops which is what I have I
have this chic like white furry ottoman
that Bennett's are not allowed to sit on
and section so they're from from lounge
Abul poof's and sectionals to stackable
chairs in the event of extra guests
which is my problem tonight you know we
only have six chairs but I'm having a
people over for dinner thank God for
article article is here to make these
articles here to help you make
entertaining season stress-free and
beautiful furniture shopping is famously
terrible over your sales people poor
quality pieces interminable shipping
periods that never work that's why
article decided to change the way people
shop for furniture instead of schlepping
to a warehouse to shop for part
particleboard are
close online catalog features high
quality pieces that you can browse right
at home their team of designers have an
eye - on today's trend but focus on
timeless design and great quality plus
they're in stock items ship in two weeks
or less I've never had such an easy time
with shipping like a litter I got a
phone call one day I forgot I even
placed an order and the guy was like oh
I have your article delivery what time
will you be home and I was like what I
literally order this week go they keep
their prices low by cutting out the
middleman and selling directly to you so
no showrooms no salespeople and no where
you tell markups the websites very easy
to use the prices are surprisingly
affordable and I feel like the toasters
will just like love article they have
been loving it so far they have flat
rate shipping across the USA and Canada
starting at just $49 with free basic
shipping on orders of 999 dollars or
above all in stock items are delivered
in two weeks or less 30-day return
policy with simple returns and exchanges
they're offering our listeners $50 off
their first purchase of $100 or more to
claim visit article com / toast and the
account discount will be applied
automatically a checkout that's article
dot-com / toast to get $50 off your
first purchase of $100 or more article
comm / toast $50 off your first purchase
of $100 or more sign on gay your home
together and very easy and affordable
way become homemaker totally okay this
story is just everything everything to
the toast
Microsoft tried a four-day work week in
Japan productivity jumped 40% you just
reminded me of something are you gonna
say now you wanna keep reading
apparently this guy running for
president named Andrew yang and I don't
think he's very popular and he's
definitely not gonna win and I'm not
being political all but he is running on
the platform of a four-day work week and
I just want to think everyone should
think about looking into him okay wow
that is program thank you and this is
why a growing number of smaller
companies are adopting a four-day
workweek now the results of a recent
trial at Microsoft could suggest it
could work even for the biggest
businesses the company introduced a
program this summer in Japan called the
work-life choice challenge which shut
down its offices every Friday in August
and keep all employees an extra day off
each week the results were promising
while the amount of time spent at work
was cut dramatically productivity
measured by sales per employee went up
by almost 40 percent
here too the same parry the previous
year the company said in a statement
last week in addition to reducing work
hours managers urged staff to cut down
on the time they spent in meetings and
responding to emails they suggested that
meetings should last no longer than 30
minutes employees were also encouraged
to cut down on meetings all together by
using an online messaging app well this
is like Malena the problem with like
these millennial companies is that
people just like make meetings for the
sake of having meetings and it's like
two hours they blocked off to like sit
in a conference room and just like pick
their noses and it's like when you have
so much time and resources and these
like big companies and there's like you
just like don't have that much to do so
like you waste time and money yeah
because you also like just want to look
like you're busy yeah as opposed to
being busy getting it done and then
leaving doing your things so that when
you come back to work you're more
refreshed I mean this is just like a
really small step in the campaign over
here at the morning toast to get the
four-day Work Week up and running and I
just I love it I think it's incredible
because we can't have a four-day
workweek here until you have a four-day
work week because we work for you and we
are here to entertain you during your
work day yeah so yeah we could like say
you know what we'll start with ourselves
but then we're leaving people hanging
Friday and I feel like the four-day
workweek won't work unless we're all on
the same page because if you like it
then it becomes optional they'll be like
you know sneaky brown nosers for the
hidden agenda like working all day
Friday making us look bad and it has to
be all or nothing if some of your
friends have a four-day work week some
have a five and then they're taking
three-day weekends and then it's like
I'm sorry I can't come til after work
it's gonna create divides in the
friendship and it's just gonna be tough
to like to plan a weekend you know and
it sounds like the group of friends like
who work Fridays and the grouper friends
who don't right so we just need to get
on the same page about this obviously
you know where we stand on this on this
pertinent pertinent issue and I think
the proof is in the pudding I have to
just one go about making this happen
like is it a law I think so look nobody
I don't think it's a law that we have to
work five days a week I guess maybe just
be every business like that's harder
like we need just the government to make
a command aid right but then it's like
we're living in a communist regime where
they tell us what days we can work
Mondays we can wrap that's a little
scary
yeah so we're not here for it you know
nobody talks it's it's just I know we're
a small company and we only employ like
three people but maybe just maybe like
we could be you know the change like the
chain reaction that starts at all if we
start and then everyone starts we could
put Nate where it's a chicken-and-egg
situation because it's like we don't get
that day off until everyone else does
you know we really need like the Google
Facebook like Instagram like the
my biggest companies in the world like
all the Silicon Valley we need them
yeah like we need Conde Nast Hearst like
we need the big companies to all sign a
petition that they're all gonna do it ya
know and I think this is like a lot of
there's a lot of change in the workplace
you know longer maternity leaves per
term and eat leaves it's it comes from a
social force and social change so we
just need to add this to the list I know
and like as I'm thinking about having
children and I realize like the five day
work week in the to Day weekend like if
you're someone who works like you're
really only hang out with your kids
twice a week like that's terrible
like we need three and four is such a
better balance and like I feel like when
someone feels more fulfilled at home
they'll do better at work yeah and then
like how does this extend to the school
week I think the kid should stay in
school just like the good job there
should be one day a week though where
the parents don't have to work and the
kids are in school because it's like you
don't expect a [ __ ] right like you don't
work technically but then you go home
after work on your kids but like there
should be a day a week where the kids
are in school and the parents ain't
working
yeah the unions to change its the unions
okay I Margo you tell them that's what I
said before we bring out Jacqueline act
I do need to remind everyone that I am
hitting up Verona New York at the Verona
can you name uh turning stones turn
those stones yeah Turning Stone Casino
in Verona New York tickets are available
at girls no job comm I'll also be in
Englewood New Jersey and Atlantic City
New Jersey tickets are also available at
Carthage a calm kansas city is almost
sold out but i think it still gotta take
it girl time job calm and we're going to
ontario the rama rama casino and resort
so just head over to girl with no job
calm tons of shows most members hold out
but we got a bunch still available so i
would love to see your faces before the
tour is over but then it would be five
days for teachers working if the kids
stay in school true and also like
everyone who runs no i think that on
that fifth day we got the substitute
teacher thrower in Holly Holly
okay we're gonna go get Jack menachem
pubic question for her feel free to
comment it on our Instagram or on the
live YouTube feed she's gonna be
answering all your questions lady gang
everything you want to know stay tuned
we will be right back with Jack the neck
you
we are back with the final and third
lady gang co-host finally coming on our
show
Jack Vinick is it the necromantic Vanek
but it's fine oh but I like the neg okay
well it's Vinick now okay yeah I'm
excited I'm not like to do that here
just wouldn't be the first time we are
very excited to have you here thank you
so much for coming like such just your
I've been following on Instagram now for
a few months ever since we did actually
I'm only like a month ago but um you
just live the life like your life is
just like colorful and you move such
premium content like yeah so we help you
we we're done podcasting we're in the
car coming back from CBS Studios and
Jackie is like I'm gonna [ __ ] threw
out to ask her what preset she is is um
well I bought yours by the way
so coming from like the preset Queen
she's been like really neat I'm honoured
great flow thank you
and it's not like your typical blog or
like a washed out like orange flow it's
like your color from your life Mahalo
I'm just trying to be colorful you know
it's really good girls do you use I use
vsco cam
well Snapseed vsco cam you're a little
bit of after lights if it means that oh
so you're a visco girl I'm never used
abisco well I just figured out what a
visco girl actually is lit i feel really
old I never heard of a hydro flask i
feel really old really yeah I still
don't understand what it is it's just a
water water the big water bottle okay so
it's like hydrofloss a website no shot
morning toast comp but that's like a
swell bottle it's a water bottle no but
specific type of water bottle it's just
a brand and it's just a metal water
bottle basically herself
yeah you know exactly me and a bunch of
16 year olds so you are um you are here
visiting your boyfriend cuz you said he
was doing show it works boyfriend's
musician ah my entire life I've dated
musicians like rocker you know why it's
I tried to stray away and then I got
pulled back in I've known my boyfriend
for 10 years and I never thought I'd
date a musician again and then Here I am
Telling You in Kelty met right yeah on a
tour we have a mutual ex-boyfriend I
mean groupies maybe sounds fun
well T described it it sounded like a
dream yes so fun I mean it's it's mm
it's kind of grueling like you've seen a
tour bus with ten other guys yeah
everybody's smelly everybody's farting
yeah you just have to like be one of the
guys but it's fine
yeah I love it and it's just kind of in
my DNA like I said I can't get away from
it so we got so many questions for you
because so you're now with your
boyfriend on tour but you went on tour
the Warped Tour the Warped Tour babe we
got so many questions about it and like
I was reading and I was like having FOMO
because I don't know what it isn't I
need to know have you ever been doing it
no okay so it's like a traveling punk
rock music tour that started in the 90s
and it just ended now like last year but
you travel the entire country and Canada
for two months straight I was there
selling my merchandise so I'd have a
little pop-up tent little Jack Vanek
bracelets and stuff so it's because I
meant to bring this up when we saw you
in LA but I used to have your bracelet
so like and I have picture it's like I
literally just like the skinnier I got I
wear them like high up on my arm you
know that was like gold did you have the
Gleek one no I had the beauty click one
I'm sure the Gleek ones I have no idea
maybe I think I had the glam one you
know so glam oh yeah would you ever
bring your Jersey I feel like you could
do lady game bracelet yeah well I'm kind
of a teacher I made it for some Jersey
boutique and it was just all the Jersey
ladies that we're buying it and Jackie
and Jackie so I'm kind of like waiting
for the bad trend to come back around
it's been like a little bit over ten
years I'm just waiting for it season I
have like 20,000 from 20,000 of them
left in a warehouse no way so I'm like
you know just waiting to make that money
I'm totally I feel like it's time it
swings back around it does every bad
trend comes back crunchies hibachis yeah
that's all I wear yeah me too
oh I mean I be never left for me he's
cute they never leave me either but
remember that scene in Sex in the City
where she tried to ruin yeah that's what
she said she's so annoying oh my god so
most of the lady game you all suppose a
crime true crime product yes
true crime podcast called the first
degree we talk about murder it is so
different from Blade II getting no not
lately more different worlds but true
crimes kind of like my passion project
and I just I love it for some reason
so speaking of true crime do you agree
that Jeffrey Epstein didn't kill himself
Oh obviously I mean we've been me yes we
have it's so crazy I love a conspiracy
theory I've fallen down the reddit
rabbit hole I'm like give it to me
inject it in my baby don't you feel like
like calling it a conspiracy theory it's
just like until today what's up yeah
because it's not a conspiracy but your
spirit theory is that a conspiracy
theory if it's true know if it's like if
it's just so obvious and it's like if
the majority of people believe this one
thing and like everybody clearly does
then it's not a conspiracy then it's
just like the narrative yeah well it's
the government trying to carve right
yeah just wait what is your favorite
conspiracy theory like what is one you
will what does the hill you will die on
like it is [ __ ] true mine is that
Beyonce didn't give birth to Blue Ivy
like she 100% out a surrogate like
theirs you could not change my mind okay
here is that this is a really random one
but that chuck-e-cheese reuses their
pizza slices Oh
like if someone didn't eat it then
they'll put it if there's a whole world
guys need to go down they have use we're
gonna find the information on this I
mean so Shane Dawson did a really good
documentary on it and but it's basically
like if somebody doesn't finish their
pizza they take all the unused pizza
slices and put them into a new pizza
because their slices never match up
there's like pepperoni on this slide
they go to Chuck E Cheese they bring a
camera there like worthy only adults
with a bunch of kids if you look like
creep oh my god they're filming the
whole process and I don't know if they
ever came to a conclusion or not
sickening wait speaking of Shane Dawson
there were so many comments on your
pictures hanging you know Geoffrey star
and like you don't know like you were
sitting next to two of his biggest fans
like in the world from the myspace days
right yeah so I used to hang out with
him in high school when he used to work
at Mac we got him back in the day
because we're both from Orange County
and we're both in the music scene he
grew up in the Warped Tour world too oh
did he he used to do like music Beauty
healer yeah oh yeah so yeah we used to
hang out all the time there is this
thing called scene Queens and it was
need a couple other girls and basically
Jeffrey who were like the rulers of the
scene world oh my
god I wish I was like hoppin mad no sign
every channel influencer is totally well
it's crazy because back on like MySpace
days everybody was like who cares about
a big following what are you gonna do
with it and now it's any what anybody
wants I mean he is the best example of
somebody that has done it freaking
perfect
can you believe like where he's at the
shane dawson taking such a series he
makes twenty million dollars i pallet
okay when you turn the calculator around
and it said twenty-eight million dollars
like I was gonna die like literally
throw no I'm like I thought that you
were missing a couple zero breakfast
this is insane
you need to get him on the lady gang I
know I know I haven't I haven't seen him
in so long he has just been like killing
it doing his thing but yeah perfect he'd
be perfect and this is what I do like
about that documentary is he is such a
good friend and he's such a good
kind-hearted boy lots of controversy
yeah however he had always been such a
good friend to me so I love that you're
seeing the human side of him I love that
you say that cuz I feel like I just and
I'm like I know he's definitely like a
good nice person you know I have no
proof of that
yeah so now you're just confirming it
yeah in my heart I know um you're also a
lady gang tour you guys been doing shows
all around yes how would I go a similar
to warp tour right it's good we did
seven shows over the summer
I mean Kelsey has a full-time job so we
had to like work it around her job we
did East Coast Texas and then West Coast
they're amazing yeah you guys know it's
so cool to like actually meet your
listeners and have that connection with
people cuz you're used to just doing
this in a room with nobody around right
you're like is anyone really listening
no like am I making up my numbers like
the numbers are there but it's like no
one's there yeah you know we're talking
to ourselves in here but can you believe
though like how much of a following and
like almost like a cult vibe lady gang
has taken on like we're always like
shook it's crazy I mean I think a lot of
it has to do with you know we started a
long time ago did been doing this for
four years I barely knew what a podcast
was and we started it people still don't
know what about oh I know but like
backing that it was like it's so crazy
so it's cool to you know girls have
grown with us yeah yeah same thing with
my brand it's I started my brand when I
was 19 years old so to have people grow
with you when they started as these old
twerpy scene kids and now everybody is
you know these awesome powerful women
and it's cool what
talk about this a lot on the show and I
would love to get your opinion on what
you think of the trend of like
celebrities now like infiltrating the
podcast base like that Shepard according
to Brian like and now Conan O'Brien
being the cover of Variety magazine
saying that he's the face of podcasting
yeah just know it's like have you ever
met Joe Rogan or yeah bleeding so I love
to hear your thoughts on this like
celebrity like infiltrating our Center
space well we had a conversation about
this when we're in LA where it's like
it's not I don't remember anything I
think we filmed it though I think it was
after but we're we need like two
different sections of podcast me yes
nobody's that started podcast and then
there needs to be a celebrity podcast
section because we can't be compared to
Dax Shepard that's not fair we can be
compared to the girls from the office
okay Jenna Fischer well obviously your
podcast is number one you guys are
freaking celebrity todai you need just
two charts just so we can like see where
we are again it's like our own like
people on our level yeah um can I take
some questions from Instagram ago we
have so many questions about your
Instagram okay how do you always manage
to find the best rooftop bar and day
drinking bar in every damn City you know
I it's just what I do I really I really
do I love traveling and I love planning
like my whole entire trip out so that's
just what my like little passionate
thing is in my free time so I spend a
lot of hours researching it oh that's
good um okay this is such a funny
question [ __ ] marry kill okay blink-182
sum 41 or simple plan just like a
question my husband would die for me he
just went to some forty one concert and
was moshing okay okay wide kill some
forty watch okay what was the first one
liquidity or simple plan I'd marry
blink-182 because they have the most
money and then I guess my simple plan
because their singer was kind of hot
pretty smart pretty good
clink 182 though if you pick one this is
from the MJ essentials if you had to
pick one first degree or lady gang Oh
pick one I mean lady gangs my og
yeah totally what's been your favorite
episode of first degree well we did a
whole series on oj we had kim goldman on
that with her justice for Ron Goldman
it's insane cuz she has her whole
podcast about confronting OJ she just
wants to talk to him and it is so [ __ ]
oh I'm sure all this [ __ ] so it was
really cool to have her perspective on
it because she is the whole premise of
our podcast is to tell stories one
degree away from their murderer or the
incident
victim so she is the ultimate
first-degree I mean she's been connected
to totally realize she's there I know
it's so crazy in your professional
opinion who do you think killed Jon
Benet good question
see it's like I always side towards the
brother but I also don't know if I've
been given biased information right
because everybody watched the
documentary and they ended up getting
sued because it was basically like
slandering right and in your
professional opinion do you think Amanda
Knox is my next question cuz we're
talking about her last week she for sure
did it no no I didn't watch a
documentary but I know that they didn't
really stress and I've had like going
abroad can make me people and saying
yeah and like what was the Italian a
whole justice system is so so [ __ ] on
right and like they didn't really harp
on the fact that like going abroad like
makes people crazy like they get this
like sense of liberation that they've
never had before I got it someone like
it's so freeing like you could murder
someone well so any foreign country like
I don't know anyone nobody knows me here
if I could do it no it's gonna come up
invincible I'll just go back home yeah
it's like if you get a parking ticket
out of state you're like what is fine I
got to pay no my thing with that is she
was acting so weird like right after it
happened but you don't know how people
are gonna act in leeward situations like
that that they're like judging her
action right and maybe she was just a
weird girl yeah she small she seems like
a weird girl she did it regardless she
also tried to crowdsource crowdsource
her wedding now she's a column in a
Seattle newspaper so it's all weird yeah
that has been owned it's always weird
one like true crime people end up
becoming celebrities yeah disgusting I'm
like you were convicted of murder and
now you're an influencer yep yeah that's
also like on the flip side though like
Elizabeth Smart like does Instagram add
while of Elizabeth children she is so I
follow her on Instagram but that is
weird that she does ads yeah she's
famous she's like a famous kidnappee you
know but like she surprised that she
should [ __ ] self a bit fun boxes you
know she said I mean it's the least that
somebody could do to do traumatized for
and hurt her entire life totally okay
this question is from bitte
shokran how did you and your boyfriend
me so I met him on the Warped Tour
it's how everything in my life has
basically started as on the Warped Tour
so crazy ten years ago we met we have
this incredible like initial connection
it was like a soulmate II kind of thing
he had a girlfriend chick so we stayed
friends but he had feelings for me so we
had to
we're like toeing the line of what was
appropriate what was appropriate what
wasn't and his feelings for me were too
strongly we had to kind of like cut off
our friendship for a while lost touch
and then recently reconnected like a
year and a half ago
that's so cute yeah that's like you know
random question you've seen a star is
born I'm assuming do you see you have it
what guys I haven't seen a movie in like
five years
his name is Jackson main like it's so
similar to your boyfriend's name and
like they're both like rock stars I mean
they kind of have a same like vibe yeah
like they play stagecoach a like yeah
you're right okay number one I was at
stagecoach when they filmed that scene
the way of Bradley Cooper no we were yes
okay we were and yes we're being filmed
yeah welcome we were a Coachella when
they did lady got she used some of her
Coachella set I don't know I don't know
well Bradley Cooper was playing on the
side of I think it was really Nelson oh
and we're like what the [ __ ] is going on
here cuz he's like at the side of this
stage but then they're filming the crowd
says but Willie Nelson was definitely
not there for that that's Willie Nelson
but I am trying to get jared into
country music I'm like this is where
it's at doesn't matter you can be so old
yep you can lose your hair you can be
gross and people still love to make him
into a country music star
oh I also love countryman dating a
country music star obviously that's a
yes we'll see you on the CMA Awards red
carpet interview today
one day yeah I'll be once the transition
of those country wives
sweet and salty what is your best career
advice that you would give to a young
professional ooh
so I think this kind of comes from
starting my brand I made so many
mistakes because I tried to like jump
ahead of myself and take too big of
steps so my probably best piece of
advice is baby steps yeah don't get
ahead of yourself it's okay to move at a
slow pace because slow and steady really
does win the race that's great you don't
you don't want to you know skyrocket
into success because you'll probably
crush them burgesses by the way that's
such great advice for that problem yet
lesbian
I had member my college I was really sad
that's correct that is that is good at
you talking about yeah tell you about
checkout oh I have a question for you
because yes so many people style icon
and like have been for years just about
your evolution of style who's your style
icon Dury Wow such is Sochi Sochi cuz I
have this thing where I'm like when do I
have to stop wearing crop tops I'm 32
years old never but I'm like she rocks
it is so amazing and is aging so well
she doesn't age what is AJ's feeling
gracefully that's such an excuse me and
she also is the most stunning person in
real life oh my god
okay the certify of a question from Lil
hazers 3 this is so funny have you ever
made up a story on good week bad week
it's hard to keep coming up with stuff
all the time yeah I've also stolen so
many other like of my friends if
something happens I'm like okay how do i
rework this to happen to me yeah yeah
when you're when you're like scratch
scribbling the for the bottom of the
barrel for content every week like
sometimes you just gotta get creative
well also sometimes we batch record
episodes because we're traveling or
company is working great I'm like well
four completely crazy things didn't
happen this week but we were like you
stuff from the past that is hilarious
I've stolen a few things one thing I
want to end on what is your good week
bad week this week good question um well
here's a good bad week my boyfriend
actually left this morning he's going to
Boston and he like wanted to get like a
little quickie in before so he comes out
of the bathroom you know with no shirt
on just underwear but he's wearing his
last pair of underwear because they
can't ever do laundry on tour and it's a
pair of old whitey tighties and he comes
in bed and I'm like you look like a babe
yeah I can't have sex with you I've seen
he's like oh [ __ ] and he's like man I
guess this works on David Beckham but
not me because he is stocky dude yeah
like not the most in shape but I kind of
like it
cuz he's just like a big guy yeah I'm a
chubby chaser yeah and I'm like this
like this is not working dude I'm like a
big baby how did they do laundry on tour
they just would stress me out they know
totally he's got to keep buying new
Hanes I mean he wore the same shirt for
four days but the thing is he doesn't I
don't know because he doesn't smell its
yeah I did say that he did say no Bo
whatsoever and I'm like I also don't
know if it's me
like liking his pheromones or not yeah
but he never smells so different for
boys like for girls like you really
cannot wear the same pair found dua for
more than 24 hours like what the guy
it's like we're the same pair underwear
for a week it's like shorts secondly
same shorts for a week guys having like
vagina issues totally no it's a whole
different ballpark um thank you so much
for coming if you want more Jack back
vadik sorry um head up on instagram j a
CVA and EK you can also hear her on lady
ink podcast and your trip hi true crime
podcast which is called the first degree
the first great Nate and um obviously
available iTunes Spotify you can find it
charting in the store any day of the
week we love you guys we'll see you
tomorrow for my final episode as I head
off to Morocco yes I'm such a
cosmopolitan [ __ ] and my birthday thing
right sorry so so Jackie's birthday
tomorrow so feel free to Center wishes
and then mo no kidding do not Batman I'm
Joe thank you guys we'll see you
tomorrow bye
you